now Sebastian AO a bunching who shoots kit
just wide Jarvis got a piece of that another
shot blocked on the way through Hughes gone in
front of it here's Hughes Queen Hughes with a
rot where's Puck loose jamming away kzo couldn't
put it home DJI poking at it as well how pass the
goal he has hit some bodies in front and he's
whacking at it the second time they run loses
his stick but does so in keeping the puck
out good job by Brady Shan just tie up the
stick kco takes the one shot at it off the
toe of the skate and then he's just trying to
muscle they'll like where he was on the
ice there to get that opportunity scored
a lot of goals from really close in last
year Noah Json with the puck in his own
Zone waiting for a change to be completed
here's Ian Cole ahead to Alias Pon carries
over the blue line now let's go the r
change direction rebound they score sh
La shot and a rebound still the best play in
hockey and lafer picked up the loose scraps
of the pon shot to make it one nothing the cans
execute a regroup up ice P's going to take the
space that's afforded him and it's off the goal
tender laer who scored a lot of goals that close
to the blue paint does so again this hits a
stick of slaven brones off balance and that
rebound Garland to hoglander pass to Garland
just on side wrist shot stick saved by Ronson
Puck sent to the line held in by Heron long shot
deflected what a save by ronto with the right Pat
after the tip by La looking through his second of
the game but he helps himself out this is deflect
at the front of the net he's down and is able to
reach out at the last moment with that right pad
laery cruising through the front of the net gets
his stick on it watched by AO passes to Miller
in the high slum pson across besser thought by
R what a save and he's a little slow to get up
on Tonto and as Carolina's hustling around it's
Brock besser with the one timer 22 seconds to
go on the power play and here's a steel slaven
trying to get loose short handed Jacob slaven
shoots dle the save he gathers the puck and
freezes it points on the power play and he
was said to talking about hey I'll for check if
I need to for check long shot by heric Carolina
I mean the first couple of shifts they were on
the puck they were making life difficult for the
con in zone Pi's Miller to hoglander trying to go
through the puck did but he couldn't stay with it
15 seconds to go in the first penalty here's AO
Sebastian AO carries down to the bottom of the
circle sends one across Burns is stopped by dco
again sliding to his right weak clearing attempt
kept in by Carolina here's NIS leaves for burns
down AO first penalty's over pass back Burns to
the side dco a blocker save off Marty NIS able to
get to it can't get it down and here's terab puts
one to bunting back to terab Cuts in front triy
to go short side and Deco able to get Blocker on
that to the Blue Line Burns again AO top of
the circle skates towards the net sends one
across GCO sliding to his left made a fine
save there no rebound and this was at the
tail end of that five on three we turned
into five on four and just recently it
was great to see all the firefighters
here firefighter night few nights ago
as M moves in centers the p p makes a
move on pesi puts one in the crease M
scores keep your stick on the ice and Alias
Patterson's likely to find
it Ilia mck makes it two
nothing lford he takes the hit to the puck
gets out of the Zone M finds the center and
here's where the play was made cter step right
to the blue paint and M is able to knock knock
this in NIS gets out battled in a stick war
and it goes towards number 65 conuts up two
nothing pson and lty the assist so they each
have two points in this game and the conuts
are back into the Carolina Zone Hugh centering
pass broken up and here comes Carolina three
hurricanes to Center fost in on the right wing
es for fost centers Martin scores hurricanes
answer right back as Jordan martinuk finishes
off the odd man rush to make it two to one
starts the play and then drives towards
the net it's kind of fluts off his stick
up over the Blocker of thater Demco
it's just heric trying to read when
that pass is coming through and Bluer
can't help out Carolina answers backra
changing is Pon passes back behind the goal
to Nils hoglander gets there ahead of burns
leaves the puck for Brock besser besser
goes away from slav sends in Fr Miller
[Music]
scores beautiful setup from hoglander and
baser and JT Miller has that 40th point on
the year making it 3 to one H glander gets body
position moves it down to besser little stop
and start and Miller's coming downhill bam on
to stuck in the blue paint look at the change
here for Miller timing and ready to shoot
31 [__] 13 46 ORF brings the puck ahead
dishes off to Michael bunson with the final
minute of the second orov inep sends one in
front they score Brady Shay put home that
pass the two defenseman combining as orov
went in deep and sent it in front and Shay
on the power play he made it three to2 and
you mentioned the two defenseman being a part of
things oloff dishes it off gets it back and as
who is looking up ice Shay's behind him and the
pucks behind dull before he can get across in
time some crisp passing they were trying
to do that with the previous power play
unit now played ahead by n last time we saw
him was in considerable pain on Puck that
hit him sharp angle shot stopped by Thatcher
Demco now Brent Burns in the blue line Burns
shoots tip and they score I think the first
shot hit the crossbar and N was there to pop
it home and 2 minutes and 10 seconds into
the third period Carolina's tied the game
at three and after thrown towards the net it's
not handled cleanly by the canuts thrown back
towards the net deflected off the crossbar
sits in the blue paint and N just swats it
in so Carolina with some lineup tweaks
to their forward grouping to start this
third period wide on Chatfield round the net
protecting the puck tees it up for Heron lets
it Go wide mm takes the puck off the in boards
in behind for Alias pson R around he [Music]
scores third point of the game for Alias
Patterson as he puts the Canucks right
back on top the shot misses the net mck's going
to put it up high P's already going to fend off
and then wrap it around on AO on R and put the
Canucks ahead shielding and then quick hands
Le has Patterson a couple of assists in this
game and now his 11th goal the season and they
do FMS tees it up AO shoots and that missed
the net can KN get to the puck clear it down
and that's going to do [Music] it three-point
night for that or Elias Pon and Thatcher Demco